[Music]
tony what a pleasure to see you thanks
for coming back on the show
tim it's great to to be with you and
with you again i hear that's a rare a
rare occasion to come on a second time
so thanks for having me it is a rare
event and i think there are many good
reasons for it the first is we only got
through
a small percentage of my total notes the
first time around and many things have
happened since we last spoke
and
i have to ask you right up front
so you have this new book build subtitle
an unorthodox guide to making things
worth making which is
incredibly well put together i looked at
it i didn't read the whole thing but i
did read quite a few chapters i'm going
to read more
lots of diagrams lots of illustrations
stories case studies
etc i was looking back however at the
transcript of our first conversation
which i always do before having a
follow-up and i had asked you what you
struggle with what doesn't come easy
and you had said analytics has always
been tough also long-form writing it's a
lack of patience you have a hard time
waiting on people to move when the time
is now he just wants to get things done
that's you
so
long-form writing but yet here we are
with a book so
what the hell happened how did how did
this come to manifest
well build has been in the back of my
mind obviously not the title but the the
concept has been in the back of my mind
for about 15 years now i've had a lot of
people bugging me when are you going to
write a book when are you going to write
a book
you know and i just didn't want it to be
some kind of autobiography or some look
at this great stuff and here's all the
wonderful things that um
the team and i created together and and
you know it's just these kind of hero
stories well i really wanted to give
back
and the the real reason for doing this
is you know i i looked up and this was
just before covet
and so
i was looking around going
you know
the only reason why i'm sitting here
talking to to someone such as yourself
is because people helped me
with my success i had mentors along the
route
and from all the way from when i was a
young kid through school into the
working world and i thought about that i
was like oh
and then i thought about who
were or are my mentors and i found out
you know most of them had died
and for me i was like oh wait a second
that means the baton has been passed and
to take you know what people gave me
their heart their their time their
energy their passion to help me with
with no economic benefit to them
directly they helped me so now it's time
for me to give back and given our work
at future shape where we have over 200
companies we've directly invested in and
lots of other companies who just come to
ask for for advice
i was being a mentor every day
and so i just started putting together
all of the topics that kept coming up
every single time every day every
multiple times a week into a spreadsheet
and start going okay this this this
these are the core things necessary and
so build was born out of just those
conversations that i have all the time
and so
to get into long form obviously long
form is difficult and i didn't do it all
myself i had a brilliant co-writer dina
lavinsky who helped me tremendously and
we've worked together for over a decade
so she and i put the words on the page
but the concepts and everything came
directly from the conversations i have
daily with all of these startup founders
or even high schoolers going into
college what should they do college
people getting out where should i go
work so it was all of those things
coming out and flowing back and
hopefully this book is a mentor in a box
so no matter whether you're a high
schooler all the way through you know
retirement age you're able to access
something
in the book and the book is set up yes
it's long form but really every chapter
and it started out as micro chapters
short chapters about real key topics
that
i think affects
most people in most industries who are
trying to do something special and for
either themselves in their career or for
the world in the in the businesses that
they they create or manage and so that
was really what it was it's just trying
to give back and it was really rewarding
it was very difficult it was very
cathartic at times it's very personal
it's very raw i didn't pull punches
and you know we'll see what happens i
hope there's real practical advice not
just about success but here's all kinds
of ways that i've failed and how i pick
myself up from the failure and moved on
because for as much success you hear
people talk about you know this tim is
there's a lot of failure along the way
that most people don't talk about and i
think we actually spend more time
talking about the failures than we do
the successes in the book so people can
learn
okay so i'm grinning ear to ear for
people who can't see me
if you're listening just the audio and
i'm i'm grinning for a whole bunch of
reasons the first is we just pause for a
second everyone listening should imagine
tony in front of
employees
say rallying them for a launch or
say identifying how they're going to
move forth or after conquering a crisis
there's a chapter on storytelling that i
just finished reading which talks about
putting the why before the what and
so you are i mean a walking
illustration of a lot of what's
discussed in the book and i want to i
want to underscore the
not pulling punches then you'll have to
trust me that i know at least some
subset of my audience
when i give this example i just
there are a lot of memorable very highly
specific stories and
they range from
org chart design all the way to handling
internal politics and different breeds
of [ __ ] and the the particular story
we don't have to get into this right
away but the story you may know where
this is going
that i broke out laughing over when i
was reading it
was having someone pull you into an
office with hr
and saying
there are two big swinging dicks in this
room and mine is the biggest and that's
how they started the meeting
and how you deal with someone like that
because
this is the unpleasant
reality of navigating the
entrepreneurial and in some cases
whether it's product or bil uh company
building
journey and so i i wanted to
now just go to this this mention of
mentors so you've had many mentors
and you can learn from mentors in
different ways so mentors can sit you
down and teach you a lesson they can
lead by example in some cases they can
show you perhaps what you shouldn't do
and you can learn from their mistakes so
i want to
visit the
killing yourself for work chapter which
i only read the very beginning of
because i didn't want to kind of spoil
any surprises for myself
could you tell us
what you learned from steve jobs about
taking vacations how did steve jobs take
vacations
well
i don't know of all of his vacations i
know of the vacations he took
while we were we were together at apple
for for 10 years and
what was really happening was you know
steve would go on vacation and in my
early days there would be like yes he's
going on vacation it's great we're you
know we're not going to have to hear
from him for seven or 14 days or
whatever the case may be
well that dream
met reality and the reality was very
different it turned out that steve you
know he would go on vacation he would
usually vacation at one or two places
and he'd go to the same places all the
time that's what he liked and that's all
good
and
he would go silent for the first kind of
24-48 hours he would be gone he would be
in transit he would be with his family
what have you for those first 48 hours
you wouldn't hear anything maybe 72 but
somewhere right after that
you started getting calls wasn't emails
it was calls from steve and steve would
be on vacation
and he would be pondering where the next
product the next direction for apple new
technologies things he's reading he used
that vacation as a time to kind of
expand his thinking and get outside of
the apple
the day-to-day and the projects that we
all knew and loved or maybe there was a
couple of things to improve on the
projects we were working on but he would
start thinking about oh let's go buy a
music company or should we go and do
this other kind of product or what
technology will it take to do this
because he's also reading he's reading
or he's listening to others saying
different technologies so he would be
calling going you would be like google
for him you're like hey what is the
latest on this and you're like uh okay
steve here's what we know i don't know
that i can go get back to you he's like
oh let me know when you know send me an
email on that and then 15 minutes later
he might call back with a different idea
and so it was literally while he was on
vacation during
reasonable hours this wasn't
wasn't crazy hours but you might hear
from him on vacation five or six times
depending on what he was thinking about
at that time per day
could be as much as a maybe zero per day
but sooner or later along that vacation
he would call you and like want to
brainstorm something or want a piece of
knowledge or want to know the latest
about something that was related to
some some idea he had in his head and so
you loved it because you got to talk to
him about all kinds of things that
weren't the day-to-day but at the other
times you were like okay steve you need
to be on vacation
and then two is how much work are we
gonna have when you come back besides
the
incredible amount of work we're already
on top of or trying to get on top of
so why did you lead with that and why
write
this this particular chapter because
flashing back again to our first
conversation which i encourage people to
read i'm going to try to not overlap too
much with that but back at general magic
you had a certain let's say approach to
work which was sure
high volume high intensity kind of 10
out of 10.
and
that seems to have have changed over
time and just for people who have no
idea what general magic is i just want
to say
and tell me if this is off base but it's
kind of like yoda warski's dune in a
sense where if people don't understand
that that was an attempt at making dune
which failed
but
the talent that was assembled
ended up being this incredible diaspora
of kind of technical
innovation that then spread all over the
place like geiger you know creating
alien and so on
so general magic was somewhat like that
i would say the genesis of a lot of
amazing careers it's a great analogy
yeah great analogy
so
why why did you lead with that story in
that chapter and why why even write that
chapter
for me i went through that personal
struggle
and i think a lot of people do of i need
to work
harder than everyone else and spend more
time working so i was working 80
100 110 hours a week kind of thing
because that's what i thought needed to
happen i thought i needed to prove
myself through the number of hours
through the amount of work that i could
get done
and i was also really passionate and
kind of like you know you're a kid in a
candy store like for me i'm a geek right
i'm like oh i can do this i can do that
and i get to work on this and the more
hours i got at there i could go and work
and learn right from all of these great
people around me so i one thing i had to
learn how to do the work and the other
one is doing the work right and learning
how to do it at a professional level
like my heroes around me would do so
there was a lot of learning and you know
when you go to school you go to school
but you're also doing your studying and
all the other stuff so it it was a
little bit more than
going to a university but your first
jobs are really like that you spend a
lot of time but you also start to learn
how to be productive okay and what being
productive means and doing a great job
versus just being there a lot of hours
and so
that's where it all hit for me i i will
say this i will i was undiagnosed add
adhd at that time frame i was in general
magic and
ultimately a couple years later then i
actually figured out what was going on
so i was trying to do my work
and and perform at a professional level
learn the work and i had adhd across all
of it so if you know anything about
writing code
right writing code and being in the
details and if your mind's always going
oh my god it made everything harder
right so it was all of those things
compounded and so that that chapter is
really about here's where i was maybe
you're
experiencing a lot of this yourself and
here's where a more balanced approach
now it's not your typical work like
daily balance but here's a way to do it
to be high performing do amazing things
but to also give yourself
the right amount per day
as well as per year of time off
right and time to think and and realize
that
when you get to go away from a certain
activity you're doing every time you
might be actually be able to think about
it more clearly and come up with the
answers more clearly if you're away from
it as opposed to into it all the time
what did you find for yourself that
annual cadence off looked like as a ceo
and i know in between gigs we talked in
the first conversation about getting
bored right spending three weeks like
reorganizing your garage and doing
something so that
the ideas that are not
obvious might
make an appearance right and you could
have insights and
we spent quite a bit chatting about that
where where have you landed for yourself
personally or where did you land as a as
a ceo
so as a ceo and and even to this day you
need for me on a weekly basis each week
was make sure you're doing the right
thing for your physical and mental
health either in the mornings or
afternoons or wherever it is
five to six days a week
and that was that's that's the first one
right there's eating healthy right so
for me there was eating healthy so i got
rid of
all kinds of bad foods i got rid of
alcohol got rid of all kinds of stuff
then there was making sure you're
physically fit making sure you're
mentally fit those are really important
things to do and you spend your time
spent a lot of time doing those and
during that time
i was able to come up with great ideas
and solve problems when i was quieting
my brain and getting out of it it was
like all of a sudden things popped in my
brain it's not that i was thinking about
it was like all of a sudden i don't know
what happened but consolidation happened
in my memory in my brain it went ding oh
that's what we've been thinking about or
thought about a differently different
perspective so that was kind of on a
weekly basis i would also go for a long
bike ride or
yoga or whatever and this was three or
four hours on the weekends really just
taking my time no devices nothing around
just totally being absorbed in in
whatever activity it was doing
and that was really really great now
let's move out to more like a year kind
of area from the week and that made sure
going on vacation
getting out of the getting out of the
fray every day when you're on vacation
really taking a vacation and turning
over the reins to people i trusted
so people who reported to me you know
they always look up and they go oh you
know i'm sure they you know they didn't
say this to me
but they're you know in the backyard oh
i could always be better why did tony
think of it this way and why did he
manage us this way and i'm sure there's
all kinds of backstories that i didn't
hear about but i'm sure they're talk
everyone talks about their manager or
leader or whatever so i was like okay
well i'm gonna just hand over the keys
to the candy store to one person on my
team and it would be a different person
each time and i was like okay now you
get to sit in the chair you get to see
from my perspective and try to manage
and lead right in that special way
and
to me it was always a it was kind of a
humbling experience both for me because
they would take it on and two they would
come back and ask all kinds of questions
right and so it was a great training
ground so they could understand how it
is to sit in in that seat and help the
team in the way that a leader can
by doing it themselves and then all of a
sudden the tables turned and there was
more empathy both ways
to each other's responsibilities
we're going to talk quite a bit about
empathy
on i think in
a number of different capacities
for instance a good story being an
active of empathy and i do consider you
a master storyteller so we're going to
come back to that but i want to ask you
a completely self-serving question first
okay
all right so we're where i suppose the
podcast in general is pretty
self-serving because i enjoy doing it
but
talking about like killing yourself for
work you have another chapter on break
points
i'd love to ask you a super specific
question and it's related to burnout for
employees who have
many hats to wear and i'll give you a
very specific example so i have very
small team
and and i'd just be curious to know how
you might think through this or how you
have seen it handled or handled in the
past
and i currently have two two full-time
employees that's it and
that's for everything and that that will
probably expand in the near future but
i'm not quite clear how to properly
expand it because i've got a lot of
conflicting advice so on one hand i have
uh someone who handles say the podcast
and for lack of a better term at
editorial they're like the general
manager of of these very specific roles
that have very specific responsibilities
and there are a fair number of wins
built into this
for them so they get a good amount of
positive reinforcement
and then the other employee is sort of
executive assistant chief of staff
probably
in the future more of chief of staff
role
and they're handling so many different
miscellaneous responsibilities
that the potential for burnout
seems to be quite high so right
and
they also get
and i need to be better at doing this
in person of course but they have fewer
kind of wins to chalk up that are
obvious that
someone say on the editorial side would
have or in any like maybe
uh like product management role where
their launches and so on
how have you
handled this in the past for yourself
for someone who's in like a an admin
support kind of broad role
do you have any thoughts that you can
share you've had so many more reps than
i have
well you know small teams are
challenging right as you say there's you
have to wear a lot of different hats and
we have a small team at future shape as
well
and so we've been working on that for
you know working that way for five six
years now so so we we deal with the same
things
similar things at least with a small
team
and i think it really boils down to me
to to well one is as you say the winds
let's talk about the winds
certain people have certain things that
have big projects they produce or what
have you and they can feel that for
people who are kind of more the
day-to-day number one is typically when
they're in those roles they like those
roles that's what they want to be okay
that's the first thing so that's what
they they naturally are accustomed and
that's what they feel good in
the biggest one for me is just saying
thank you a lot and acknowledging even
the little stuff acknowledging that yes
you're going through i know there's so
many things so many different hats
you're wearing what have you
can i help with prioritization is there
something we can prioritize there's
something we can remove from that list
at least temporarily to help you make
get through the day are there better
tools we can get are there any other
suggestions that you might have for us
to upgrade our our capabilities to allow
you to have other superpowers so you can
get more things done or the things that
just none and unnecessary so it's this
general it's first it's thanking for
even the smallest stuff and the second
thing is really talking about tools
processes prioritization of
of managing and at some point you have
to add people right you don't want to
add too many people but you want to add
in the right amount and as you start you
as the leader start to understand the
prioritizations and what's falling off
either one they don't really need to be
done or they really need to be done and
you have to start bundling that into a
new role right the other one is making
sure that you're taking regular breaks
because podcasting as we know is is
really time consuming there's a lot
happening all the time and just shutting
down for two two weeks every so often
and everybody shuts down right yeah and
they all go away i've always wanted to
do this thing where email clients the
send of email and even the receive of
email would actually go offline so it
would just be bundled and buffered in
the server and it would only turn on for
certain hours i thought that was going
to be a nice next generation kind of
thing for companies to offer to their
employees which was really work time
around the communications thing and so
if you can
find a time to take everybody away from
the day-to-day
that is another way to really reward the
team and make sure that there are they
actually have the time off as well
yeah definitely
if you don't mind i'd love to just spend
a few more minutes on this because i
get asked
all the time by friends of mine of
people i'm sure we know and comment also
i'm not going to call them out who ask
me for help with this because i have
done a lot of experiments but
when you have had more than one person
in a
let's just call support roll
where they wear many hats
what type of
division of labor have you found to
work this could be from 10 years ago it
could be today but when people are
really handling a lot of different tasks
and if if a
miscellaneous new task pops up they tend
to be the first person in line to handle
that what type of division of labor have
you seen work or not work
it really boils down to the people
especially in the small in the small
teams it all really
what your team likes and so
there is either
there's either time or task sharing or
there's time or task separation okay so
there could be two in a box for handling
all of your exec and all of these little
things and
the two people really love working
together whoever they are and they know
how to self-manage between them they
they look like one person even though
they're two people and they can manage
around the clock or you know depending
on when people are have personal time or
what have you so there's that kind of
task sharing slash time sharing
and that's been that can work really
well but those people have to get along
and they say they want to do that right
then there's the other one which is task
separation which is really
you know what it's like okay there's
your travel schedule or there's your
calendar or there's
doing
briefs for
a podcast or finances or reports or
whatever those are and then just getting
people into each of those things and
then making sure that
to me i always try to make sure i have
proactive people on the team when it's a
small team so that they're working
together and then i only insert when
there's either prioritization thing or a
little process of who does what because
i want them to self-manage i've managed
so many teams i'd rather not manage
people to tell you the truth i'd rather
mentor and be there as an advice but if
you need me to manage i'll happy to do
it but typically the best people to
manage if they're proactive and they're
they're similar to our kind of character
they like to manage themselves and they
like to manage between each other and
then i tell them well what do you want
to do just tell me what you want to do
and if that works for you and i think
it'll work for me then we go on and we
try that and then we modulate so there's
no real rules it really boils down to
the people absolutely the people and
then when you get past
if you're one leader in a small team you
get past 12 13 people that's when the
first break point really starts to
happen like you
recognize in the book like
there's those break points at different
team sizes it becomes that where there's
even more specialization and more
management if you want to just be a
leader that's
delegating to everyone and there's a
chief of staff well that's a different
story but i like to keep it very flat
get everyone to learn how to work
together how to communicate together
read each other's tea leaves if you know
what i mean and be proactive because
they know we know how to work so that's
my preference
thank you for spending some time on that
no problem hopefully it helps
it is helpful and this is this is very
current for me and write down write down
job descriptions write down roles and
tasks and be very very specific on the
things that they should be specific on
and other things that are like these are
the general pool of things that we work
on and then it's a grab bag and you can
give them out to people or they can just
jump in and take them but yeah even
though you might be small
write it down because once you write it
down and you know this it's visible and
you go wait a second that seems too long
that that's too many things they're
doing and then you can have a discussion
and you know we don't all ever want to
add more people to the team because we
think you know lean mean is better but
at some point
you're killing each other you know
because you're trying to do too much so
either do less or you got to add
capabilities and
and hands to the situation yeah i think
that's sort of the decision the point in
the decision tree where i am right now
and
i think
if i could use word
intuitively the time sharing appeals to
me because it implies
that you have redundancy and so much as
you have
two people who can handle all of the
respective buckets
kind of under their
job description
i worry a little bit that if it was task
separated that there would become
there would be vying for
more interesting or less interesting or
if
there were some overflow if someone were
handling say finance and investments and
kind of more technical
stuff that if they were asked to do
personal they might bulk for instance
like a very small team we also move the
tasks around we also move the task
around so not everyone's doing the same
thing each half year oh that's great
idea so you can move it around because
you want everyone to learn each of the
different
things oh that's a great point that
keeps it interesting for everyone as
opposed to get locked in the rut because
i don't know how much you want to grow
your business your platform right and
and for us i've been very clear is i
don't want to add any more we already
have too much to do and to add more
people is just going to be more things
on my head and everyone else's said
we're like no we're going to just stay
small because we can be we don't have
any business goals to grow beyond that
so the other thing is not just your team
but understand what you need what you
want what are your goals as the leader
for your what you're trying to do you
know you can be everything if you want
to be but then that comes with all kinds
of other resources you need to add in
and just be really cognizant if you love
your life and everything's working just
because somebody else has got oh well
they have you know
more followers or they have three houses
and you know whatever like what is
meaningful for you and what's meaningful
for your team to really be doing and is
everyone financially taken care of yeah
start there don't think about oh i want
to conquer the world maybe you do but a
lot of people don't and you're you're
very successful as you are how much more
i don't know that's for you to answer
yeah i mostly just want to hike in the
woods with my dog and uh barbecue my
girlfriend
well then
maybe you gotta do just slightly less
or add one person yeah i think you and i
have
a number of converging interests we're
going to talk about a little bit later
let me ask you with future shape
what does the
head count and org chart
look like within future shape since
you've had the opportunity to kind of
design
many different teams what is what does
future shape look like
future shape depending on how you count
is
you know around nine people yeah when
you factor in all of the accounting and
all the other pieces about nine to ten
people and they're both on the west
coast and also here in france so we have
on both sides but
truthfully
future shape is a set of individuals
i might be a leader in a way but
everyone on the team is a leader for the
expertise they bring and so it's all
proactive we're all friends we all want
to help each other we're here for a
mission
and so we want to keep it flat lean and
mean because the reason why
at least i am and a couple other people
are
on the team is
we don't need to work in a corporation
we don't need to work in
something much more highly structured
we are
professional adults we can all we know
how to work together and
we just want to do really great stuff
within reason while having great lives
obviously there's peaks and valleys and
all that stuff but
like now with the book it's it's very
peaky right now but um
i do know that feeling yeah people are
burning the midnight oil now but you
know typically it's not like that and we
try to make sure it isn't like that you
know even though we have two different
time zones we're very respectful on each
other's time zones even when we're
traveling these kinds of things so
the nice thing is because we have two
the teams on both sides there's only
wind on both sides of the atlantic
there's only windows of time when we can
each be working together if you know
what i mean
and so it's a great self-limiting
function so i find these kinds of things
really interesting the other
self-limiter is because we're an
investor we're limited by only our
family funds we don't have lps so we're
not always chasing the next billion
dollar fund or two billion dollar fund
so we also have an internal pressure you
know pressure there which is we're only
going to be doing our capital right so
we have to manage this portfolio so we
try to make sure we have constraints
on our time on our resources such that
it doesn't allow us to grow
too big so it's like the aquarium fish
and aquarium it grows to the size of the
aquarium size or the fishbowl side so i
try to make sure we put those
constraints on it team size how much
we're doing those kind of stuff to make
sure we don't spill over right and if we
do spill over then we just say okay
we're gonna do less you know it's hard
you always want to do more because you
see lots of interesting things you see a
lot of
incredible teams but you can't do it all
yeah when you have to say no i think we
discussed that on our last podcast
saying no a lot and so really what's
your mission what are your goals
personal and also the team goals
and make sure it's all aligned
could you
mention
just describe in brief the
mission of future shape and then if
you're open to it would you mind
describing
the set meetings that you have in terms
of whether it's one-on-ones or
all team meetings like what the cadence
of set meetings
looks like
if if they exist are heartbeats yeah
that's a chapter in the book heartbeats
so for our team again this is not we are
we are mentors we call ourselves mentors
with money yeah
we're not a vc who takes third party
money and and invested on behalf and
have to worry about returns for lps or
limited partners
we're not philanthropic so we're not
just giving away money either sometimes
it feels like that because you know we
do have failures and stuff like that you
know we still have a portfolio that
between 70 and 80 of the portfolio will
be a failure or a push you know in terms
of like the financial outcome but the
other 20
or 25 percent could be really
dramatic
so that's kind of the framing of where
we're at but to talk about what we're
really passionate about our mission our
mission is to deploy
our our network
our expertise into these companies doing
really hard disruptive
typically deep technology companies
who can be disruptive to a given
industry
and that is either in the in in the
environment
it's either a society societal issues
problems we want to solve or
health issues so
really the planet
society or or health individual health
so that's what we're focused on and we
get to work with some of the
best entrepreneurs in the planet trying
to help
help in a big way we don't invest in
sales technology or media technology
gaming we don't do that
marketing or ad technology we care about
doing the things that most people
most investors will shy away from things
that are not in vogue things that are
not like we hear about metaverse or
whatever that kind of stuff no we don't
we don't play those trends typically
we're pre-trend so before the trend
happens we're early and like we've been
doing the climate investing for a while
now and
it was crickets people are like you guys
are crazy what are you investing in this
stuff we had 2008 with the green tech
implosion it's never going to turn why
are you spending all this time tony
kovitt hits then all of a sudden people
start changing their priorities whether
that's the investment people themselves
or their limited partners and and family
offices are starting going well what do
we have in climate change what's out
there and now they're starting to call
me
they're going wait a second you've been
in this in a while what are you working
on
what are the cool companies what should
we be investing in so typically
we are ahead of the curve it can be
lonely at times but now it's finally
hitting in many of our different aspects
of what we invest in and it's like okay
finally it was right place right time
but you know there are years when you're
sitting there navel gazing going is this
going to go is this just a pipe dream we
know that there are problems when is the
world going to wake up to them because
we're solving pains we're not just doing
things frivolously and doing fun things
we think we're doing very important
things and that's what drives our team
that's what drives us now as far as how
we work our our day-to-day
we were virtual well before covent okay
we're a virtual team we have you know
we're even more virtual now but before
covert we're virtual okay we have one
physical office now we had two physical
offices but even then we were virtual so
when kovet hit we all said what did we
do we were like well what we've been
doing for the last two years so that
went really well
we're always on the messaging apps going
back and forth but we have
regularly either every week or every
other week all team meeting
okay it's just an all-team meeting we go
down here's our work list here's what's
going on funny stories just keeping that
team esprit de corps alive and going
it's very operational
all the fun stuff happens in our group
chats where we're sending each other
posts about this or funny stories or
what have you and then we're we're
probably talking to each other almost
every day one on one or one on two or
something like that or we have
conference calls with our portfolio
companies who are mentoring or ceos or
what have you so it's so we get to pick
and choose our schedules and so that's
really
unlike a lot of other companies you know
and other businesses we're in a in a
special space so we try to make sure our
lives and our mission are are paramount
in in the work that we do
this is going to be maybe a mundane
tactical question but i i know companies
that use slack i know companies that use
many different tools most recently some
have started using telegram what do you
use for group chat out of curiosity
so interestingly enough we we we go
between whatsapp and we go between of
all things skype
no kidding why yeah tell me more well we
started on skype years ago before all of
this other stuff and
and it works you know it's not
maybe not the most modern but it works
we have had
more or less less issues with that
group chat
than anything else you know
i don't know why maybe we also have less
noise in it because very few people use
skype so it's kind of like our own
messaging client without all of our
friends and family in it because if
you're on whatsapp i got friends family
i got all kinds of crazy
very few people use skype so we get it's
kind of our own messaging app that's all
our own thing you know it's kind of like
a slack channel without being a channel
yeah so we
were uncluttered so let me ask you about
something i know absolutely nothing
about but i would love to hear you
expand
or just explain what it is if
if you're able to take a minute and that
is programmable electrification so i've
read this is
something that you have been interested
in at least as recently as 2020. i don't
know if that has changed but
could you speak to what that is in some
of the areas that you're focused on if
you're open to mentioning them that are
pre-trend
sure i think programmable
electrification or truly the
electrification of everything which also
includes the wireless of everything if
you go all the way from
the place where you first start where
energy is produced or created and it
goes through the transmission lines or
wherever it is and then where it's
consumed
there's all kinds of things the same
thing goes with wireless there's all
kinds of things in the middle or at the
ends that are consuming generating
inefficiencies and that stuff so we look
across these entire
value chains
in these systems and we look at
fundamental things that need to change
in those systems to be able to make them
more efficient
so today you know this is an electrical
injury but all energy in the world today
that is created
60 of that 60
is lost in inefficiencies wow it doesn't
even do work so just imagine what our
climate crisis would be if we just saved
that energy
okay if we saved even half of that 60
like 30
we could still live the life we're
leading without all of these you know
without all the problems we have because
we're just throwing it away we're just
being wasteful you know when you've seen
people with to me waste is horrid i
i abhor waste i loathe waste when i go
to the trash can each day i'm like okay
this is organic i know where that could
go but where is this thing going where
is that thing going and it drives me
nuts
and so when i see something like 60 of
energy
goes away
in losses i'm like where can we go
target that so one thing in this is
better motors electric motors and that's
from not just cars but all the way to
electric appliances everything that uses
motors manufacturing so many things use
motors and we're throwing away tons into
fans on your ceiling tons and tons of
energy there
so
one company that we invest in is turn
tide and we've been there well before
they before they were named turn time
we've been in at all
six seven eight years now
they're making a next generation
motor and that motor can
be much more efficient like
10 15 more percent efficient but it uses
fundamentally new software and hardware
technology and gets rid of rare earth
magnets all the things that we keep
talking about with supply chain so it's
a very very different motor much higher
efficiency
slightly higher cost in certain regards
but that'll come down over time but it's
such a dramatic reinvention of the motor
that we had to be in it because energy
losses and motors is just very high and
they're used everywhere so let's go
after that another company that we're in
is called menlo micro menlo micro is all
about the distribution of electricity
from place to place today we have things
that are called relays
you've probably heard of them you've
probably heard of click click click
click and thermostats and various
appliances or whatever
those have not been innovated since the
1880s i think it was or 1850s
electromagnetic relays and silicon state
relays solid-state relays have really
not been innovated they're the same
thing but they have all kinds of
inefficiencies or reliability problems
there's been no there's been no moment
the same is like when the vacuum tune
became a transistor and all of a sudden
all of these things changed in the world
so that vacuum tube to transistor moment
is now about to happen in relays and
it's happening by menlo micro and so
it's these little mem switches they're
silicon switches and they switch very
fast very reliably billions of times and
can replace all of these these old
technologies 20 billion or more are sold
a year
today and with this we can get much
better energy efficiency and getting it
out of the transmission lines
out of the the problems in the cars in
all the traffic signals in the world in
your in how you do your lighting in your
houses or dimming or fans and all those
kinds of things so that's another
example of this kind of getting into the
electricity system and trying to find
those inefficiencies and get rid of that
waste and so to me this is incredibly
beneficial it's so much so that like
menlo has an incredibly long set of
customers because these engineers have
been working for years with this
antiquated technology now suddenly they
said finally the holy grail and they're
diving in
and
to give one example the
country of india
eight percent of all their electricity
today is used by ceiling fans in homes
eight percent of energy consumption
ceiling fans yes if you put our one
switch in just in the wall switch
we can save
50
of that so
we can go down from eight percent of the
of the country's energy consumption down
to four percent
just because their waste it turns into
heat that at this one little switch
that's not very expensive at all like
you're like oh my god what other things
can we do like that with all kinds of
other countries who have these kinds of
we all have the inefficiencies it's not
just india it's the us it's europe it's
everywhere
what else can we do when we have these
fundamentally new things that are not
you know cool and
of the moment like a metaverse or nft or
something this is the stuff that matters
that's why we we get up every day and go
to work and have a great time with this
kind of mission finding these people
doing these kinds of things that'll take
six seven eight ten years to actually
realize but once they're there they're
transformative everywhere in the world
let's return to storytelling
we've been
listening to storytelling from from
start to finish but i want to read a
truncated
two sentences
from from the book and there's more to
of course this entire chapter but the
story doesn't exist to sell your product
it's there to help you define it and
there there's more on that second
sentence but could you elaborate on this
place because i think this is a
really fascinating and deeply
important point so the story doesn't
exist to sell your product right so a
lot of people make something then
they're like all right what yarn do we
spin what do we pitch how do we
angle this properly so we can sell it it
but if if we then reframe it it's there
to help you define it
that is the product what does that mean
and could you give an example
you hit it right on the nose here so
the story
what i what i grew up learning which you
just mentioned is that you create
something you really think is meaningful
and then you at the end you go we're
going to market it now and we're going
to tell a story about it and hopefully
that story resonates and hopefully it
relates to the product you're actually
delivering what the product can deliver
right and you're like okay if you
actually move that story to the front
while you're concepting whatever it is
you're trying to build trying to create
when you actually create that story you
have to
as you know you have to understand your
audience you have to understand why
they're tuning in what their problems
are how you can solve them and how you
make it easy for them to listen in and
and learn right and hopefully some tools
so they can apply it in their day-to-day
life after they get done so that it it's
kind of almost like a a loyalty thing
they're like oh he did all these great
things for me i want to listen more so
it's not just a one-time thing but it's
a relationship that you're building even
though it might have started out as a
transaction right so how do we tell that
story
what are the pains you're solving why
does it matter why does it matter to the
individual why does it matter maybe to
their family why does it matter to their
society or where they live
how is it going to help them both
rationally and emotionally in other
words is it about money savings is it
about some time savings what's the
rational part of the story what's the
emotional part of the story to say oh
that is so cool i want to get off my
butt and actually make that transaction
happen because i really believe in
i believe in it i believe in the
rational part
so
you need to have this incredible balance
of understanding your audience
understanding all of these variables and
you need to write them down before you
embark now it doesn't mean on the on the
creative journey but it does help to
guide you so you don't get off track and
you just start building things that
resonate with you but don't resonate
with anyone else general magic was a
perfect example of that general magic we
were making all the things that we
thought were cool because we knew though
those problems would exist sometime in
the future we're going to make all of
this technology in service of what we
think is the coolest thing
but we really didn't have a great idea
of who we are targeting why we're
targeting with society ready for it what
were the both rational and emotional
reasons for buying it all those things
and that's why general magic failed
because the technology wasn't even ready
yet but the market was so far from being
ready even if the technology was close
there seems to be
a
threading the needle here
that
you have accomplished quite a few times
not just in building but also in
investing where
and this is going to sound like a
strange comparison but
i was reading a book called of wolves
and men by barry lopez one of my
favorite non-fiction books going to
redefine the genre of nature writing and
what it could be just in terms of
complexity and nuance and and beautiful
prose and he talks about
i gave several examples of wolf packs
that would set off in a
very particular direction at like high
speed or with with great intent and then
intervene
with a
migrating caribou occurred like four
days later so
they weren't sort of following the puck
or weren't following the action where
the puck would be in an obvious way
two seconds hence they were actually
converging with the caribou in this case
i'm using it as a clumsy
metaphor for sort of customer and
customer demand right because you're
talking about the investments you're
making in the electrification of
everything and the motors
where
it's sort of a seven to ten year time
horizon the problem is known
and
i would love to to know
of another example if you give another
example of
using
the story to help you define
the product and i mean one example that
jumps to mind and you could use another
one
that is that i also had never been
exposed to
was
steve jobs
presentation for the launch of the
iphone and how people this is directly
from your book we're saying oh my god
it's so amazing he has no notes and your
point was yeah of course he has no notes
because he has been honing that with
every person he met kind of like you
know jamie foxx working on stand-up
material for the last
several years of course
exactly so could you speak to that or
any other examples that come to mind
well first let's just talk about the
example which is this book
so we went through those same tools who
are the audience what are we trying to
solve what's the right form factor for
them doing micro chapters versus full
chapters how much is story how much is
advice how much is just kind of giving
more tools right it's trying to find all
those balances so if you look at the
tools that are in the book we actually
filled those out for and we gave the
press release for the book for telling
that that brief story up front here's
what the the book's about and we did the
raw ones not today but the raw ones when
we started to help us form this form the
mindset so it could help us
make sure we stay on track right we
could write the book read the press
release or read some of the tools go
back and we could then obviously change
the tools if necessary but we would go
back and forth and iterate to make sure
we're staying on track so so just to
interrupt for one second so just for
clarity with the people listening so you
wrote the press release for the book
before setting kind of proverbial pen to
paper to write the book
correct absolutely got it absolutely got
it now there might have been ideas on a
outline right like we had an outline in
terms of a spreadsheet of here's the
different things i want to talk about
but it was more like okay what is this
what are these ideas going to form into
and that's when the press release
happened and that was the same thing
that we would share with the publishers
possible publishers who were bidding on
the book going this is what it would
look like so we had to use that same
thing to communicate to people who
wanted to buy the book right because
they're a customer too well what is this
thing you're building right and we
hadn't even put maybe a page a page and
a half of some pros down it was
literally that blank sheet of paper but
with a great idea that was
encapsulated enough i think it was one
page or one and a half page press
release and it's part of the book it's
actually in the book
oh i missed it okay can you give us a
teaser or anything
that that jumps to mind that really
stood out to you or just that comes to
mind now from that press release does
anything
come to mind that was particularly
important
later kind of in the execution of the
book
i think
one of the things was mentor in a box
right was really trying to make sure
that we spent more time and advice
there are so many stories we could tell
right and there's so many things that
people want to hear more and more
stories but we want to make sure that
there was take away usable advice
and the reason being is so many people
are so busy these days that any great
leader entrepreneur or even somebody in
their career if you want to read and get
in depth
they're going to have to read 40 books
on all these different topics
summarize them for themselves and then
kind of figure it out well we want to be
the exact opposite that's why we call it
encyclopedia go learn about all these
different topics and here's some
suggestions of other books so you can go
in further if you need them so it was
really trying to be a mentor right not a
storytelling biography what have you
that's that we had to trim a lot of
stuff out because that just
we wanted to be takeaway you know quick
takeaways
advice real usable advice and we wanted
to be easily digestible so as you know
in the book it's not really a you can
read it linearly if you want but it's
really dive into one chapter dive into
one micro chapter another micro chapter
to pull out what you wanted and the
format is even
as you know there's a summary at the
beginning and then we tell the stories
to see if like the summaries here if
that summary hooks you then you're going
to probably want to hear the stories and
the practical details behind them and so
all of that stuff came specifically out
of that press release and the tools we
used in the book to make sure we stayed
on track because we wanted to make sure
it was
accessible to any age high school and
above
now you wanted to know more about i
think you said about steve well what was
the specific question oh i just brought
up steve
as a possible segue into an example
which you gave of the book
of
the story so to speak that people
thought was
developing for the presentation having
been worked on forever right it had
actually been refined over such a long
period of time
that's where i got my whole learnings to
tell you the truth about
doing this stuff up front and steve
didn't have the same we're writing the
press release up front
but what he would do is in his mind he
would start nailing the top parameters
of the story what are the problems we're
trying to solve who are we talking to
how are we going to solve them why are
we solving them and he would then use
that message and talk to his either us
as the team or to his trusted people
around him his friends or whatever and
give this pitch
daily
right and he would be refining it and
refining it and refining it and so when
it came time at the the presentation it
was just natural and guess what
the product met those things because
maybe we had to make some changes to the
product over time because of you know
during the development because we
couldn't get the right
technology or who knows what we can't
get done in time schedule issues so he
would keep modifying that and making
sure it's a crystalline little gem that
made sure it solved the problems that
we're trying to solve because a lot of
times you get into uh you know into
schedule issues or whatever should we
delay the project should we just throw
this feature off off board should we not
do this what have you and that press
release or his story were those guiding
things to go no this is so important
because i talk about all the time this
cannot
we cannot lose this so that means we'll
have to push it back maybe in the
schedule to make sure we get this as
opposed to just throwing things out just
to make a date and your story
erodes yeah it falls flat when it when
it shows up yeah you lose the load star
right if you're getting that sympathetic
resonance with your audience per se
because you've refined this thing so
well
using that as the the true north of
sorts for all these decisions
let's let's do a hard left here for a
second and talk about
[ __ ] so you have a chapter
on [ __ ]
and i think the opening line under the
summary is plenty of people think i'm an
[ __ ] so
could you and maybe a way to approach
this is just to ask you
what the
what the what the right breed of [ __ ]
is and not not all [ __ ] are created
equal so we don't have to go through all
of the the variations the different
species that you spec out we could
but
why why have plenty of people thought
that you're an [ __ ] and and how would
you kind of delineate
acceptable versus unacceptable [ __ ]
okay so this was a chapter that was very
hard to write
it took seven or eight full rewrites to
get there
and
it was very cathartic
the reason being
is that
in my heart of hearts
i know
that
who i am and i and i've had
significant people tell me i i really
try not to be an [ __ ] okay
but there are certain things that are
core to me whether that's ethics morals
values or certain product features that
need to happen and they have to happen
with a certain quality level
certain customer experience or certain
technologies that need to exist and you
push and you push and you push
because you're trying to deliver for the
customer
so there are these [ __ ] and you know
even people have called steve that too
right people have all said oh yeah
the question is is motivation
what is motivating that and when i mean
behavior i mean like pushing people i'm
not saying offending people i'm not
saying degrading people i'm not saying
you're worthless that should never be
allowed period no bullying that none of
that should be allowed but challenging
people pushing them to be better pushing
themselves to be better the team to be
better making the product better that
does not make an [ __ ] that makes
somebody who cares and i care so much
that it may come off as an [ __ ] but
it's just that passion and that caring
that matters because it's all in service
of the customer and the team slash
company slash mission
a lot of times when you see [ __ ]
it's about them their ego and their
self-centeredness
so really you have to understand why
[ __ ]
who might feel that way you know the
knee-jerk reaction oh he's an [ __ ]
he's just always on my back he's
well are they literally degrading you
are they making you feel less are they
pushing you down so they feel better
that is definitely an [ __ ] if they're
there to push the details to really make
sure everybody's
doing their best without insulting them
without like telling them whatever
just horrible behavior but making people
go white and asking why five times why
is why can't we do this why can't we do
this why can't we do this
to me that is as we say a passionate
hurricane in the book
somebody who people don't always like to
work with but
at the time but usually years weeks
months years later they go my god that
was an amazing experience and yes it
sucked and yes it was hard but i did the
best work i possibly could and it was in
in service of our mission that's what
matters and so you have to really
delineate the two even though there are
characteristics that might be shared or
ways that you react the person who's on
the other side react to it be like oh
you know they're defensive or they're
worried about their ego or they're
getting bruised
if it's about the work and it's about
the mission not about the person
then that's really the delineation there
for those people wondering where i
pulled out
the the opening salvo
in
in the office with hr at the beginning
of our conversation that was from that
chapter so you also give practical
advice on how to deal with sort of
political [ __ ] with machiavellian
techniques sometimes they don't always
work but sometimes you have to try you
have to try because sometimes people are
just having a bad day or
sometimes they're just scared and you
just got to build a relationship with
but yeah sometimes it isn't the case and
sometimes you just have to get away if
no one can help you
yeah sometimes the answer is quitting
exactly last time we spoke
we spent quite a bit of time talking
about plastics
is this something that you have
continued to focus on i'm wondering if
you've had any particular insights
related to that discoveries or if you
have
maybe segued from that to
other angles on the same or related
problems
well plastic is still forefront of my
mind i continue to work on it
it is not going away until the plastic
problem has been mainly solved i'm not
gonna i'm not going to stop all right
but in the meantime in the last three
years or so two and a half years since
we last spoke
there's been a lot happening which is a
great way so i'll give you some examples
right here like i don't know if you can
see this but if you know that logo
that's a chanel logo and that's a cat
okay i see it yeah it's hard to see with
the black background but it looks like
yeah so if people are on audio it looks
almost like a if you're old enough to
know what the hell a film canister is
yeah it's just a cap for a perfume
bottle but it has a chanel logo on it
and then this
that's a plastic cup you know it's just
a regular plastic cup yeah i have a
whole box of all kinds of things i won't
bring them out but this is a company in
the nordics that makes these are full
home compostable plastics
so they're taking bio materials and
creating fully home compostable plastics
to the the level of quality for someone
like a chanel or a luxury brand and you
can go all the way to day to day kinds
of things if we ever lose it in the
environment or whatever it will just it
will actually get eaten by the microbes
in in the soil and it will disappear if
you can throw in a compost pile this
stuff is real it's now in production and
this wasn't necessarily there just two
or three years ago and it's gotten
better and better and better so those
are the kind of companies we're looking
at that said we're also i have you know
a couple of companies that i've been
working on a trash to treasure what
other things can we take as trash and
turn them into treasure so
traditional plastics how can we turn
those into treasure i can't talk about
it right now but we're gonna have a very
exciting thing to talk about in in nine
months time probably in a big big way
but that's been something that i've been
working on
i've been looking at e-waste and how do
we extract all the
minerals and the elements out of the
gold and palladium and silver and all
these things out of e-waste and other
waste streams in general because why go
dig up more of the earth e-waste meaning
devices yeah e-waste being yeah all of
our phones our computers our tvs what
have you all those elements have been
already extracted from the earth let's
just reuse them so a lot of this stuff
is about reuse
and trying to take
today's trash and turning it into
treasure so
plastic is a big one but that's not the
only one that we're looking at because
we think it's an underserved category
tip of the spear
some people are looking at it now
battery recyclers are getting into the
act like redwood materials those kinds
of things there's going to be much more
of this over time because it's so much
cheaper to extract
from from a waste stream than it is to
extract from the planet
and better for the environment
so you have a small team
i'm sure very capable hyper capable
people if you have a small team
within
the safe scope of
let's just call it climate solutions or
technologies that have that are both
attractive in and of their own
right for various reasons but have some
let's just call it beneficial impact on
the circumstances we find ourselves in
how do you
apply constraints to that so you have
positive constraints that you've applied
elsewhere in the company in terms of
total head count and various other
ways that you've
applied constraints
how do you choose your targets and make
sure that you have a a focus how do you
eliminate things
well first is it's a wide funnel so it
really is based on do they have a cool
mission are we curious about the
technology is this something that's
important is this a really big market or
a really big problem that is solving
something for let's say the climate
crisis and it could be anything so it's
not just materials or just
petrochemicals or carbon capture we look
across everything so because frankly at
the end of the day the reason why we do
this is because we love to learn and
you got to really understand the systems
thinking as opposed to just one thing if
you're really going to solve the
problems we have so we like to look
broad very broad
both from a technology perspective value
change perspective as well as regional
perspective or country based so we look
at all this and that's just
how many cycles we have to learn and how
many people bring us interesting ideas
so that's kind of the top of the funnel
but as we narrow down there's a few
things one is
can this be deployed on mass
in the next 10 years
and is it going to be disruptive is it
going to be like we talked about that
the switch you know that from the the
vacuum to the transistor but this
electrical distribution
mem switch
it is can be applied to so many things
along the way and it's so disruptive
we're like that needs to exist when it's
disruptive and not just evolutionary but
it's going to change the players on top
it's going to change the products
fundamentally it's going to bring a
win-win-win for the environment as well
and customers as well as the
manufacturers that's when we see big
gains like we're talking about the
motors as well
so we want something with disruptive
wide impact because that's what it's
going to take to help fix this planet we
can't just have little there's no silver
bullet for this we've created so many
different systems over the last 150
years most of them
almost all of them have even been
thought about in a circular fashion you
know and how to get the trash or how to
make it more efficient it's just like oh
it works
but it works for that business not for
the planet for us as a society so those
are the kind of things that we really
look to and that's how we narrow that
funnel so that's the first thing is does
the technology is it disruptive
is it close to being marketable you know
is it close to being a product the third
thing is
and this is one of the most important
things that we've learned across all of
our portfolios is there a way that we
can quickly scale
so because we have to we have to reboot
the planet this is not just oh we gotta
go we'll do one industry in this one
state or somewhere in this country we're
talking about when we say classic
problem it's around the world when we
talk about energy and efficiency it's
around the world so if you have
something
we want to see the disruptive technology
that it's it meets it's it's it meets a
lot of needs and can be out of the lab
and into people's lives within 10 years
in a mass scale and do you have the
technology for scale in other words
a lot of times when we see well we don't
want to just hear about your one factory
what is your scale plan for making a
hundred of these factories so we can
quickly deploy them around the world
right
how can we get this stuff moved quickly
to to every corner of the planet because
we all have these problems so i think
those are the three fundamental things
that helped us to narrow that funnel
down and then there's obviously the
financial terms and if we can help and
you know all the other stuff but the big
the broad strokes are really those three
things
all right so i'm gonna dig dig a little
deeper on this and i just want to
mention briefly and i can never
pronounce his last name maybe you can
maybe you can get it right but rather
than butcher it chamoth most people know
who i'm talking about when i say chimas
sure chamath yeah it has said you know
the first trillionaire in the world is
someone who's going to fix climate
change or greatly contribute to to
climate change uh so there's a lot of
there i do think
having just watched kind of the sea
change in the last few years there's
there's some really some tremendous
tremendous opportunities
for for just let's just call it
cold-blooded capitalists who want a
great return on investment
there are many technologies and
solutions being developed now that that
if we're talking about direct consumer
or
products and consumers use the consumers
will choose over alternatives
so i think it's become really
exciting
on the playing field
you mentioned now there are certain
things that i would say are
seem obvious and get discussed a lot so
let's just say adoption of solar maybe
subsidies from the government such that
we have less dependence on
on fossil fuels and foreign especially
foreign energy
but
i had never
realized as you described that so much
energy was lost just due to
inefficiencies from point a to sort of
point z
what are some of the
uncrowded or underestimated
targets let's just say or areas related
to climate change that you you think
people should pay more attention to
there is what you can do personally and
there's what it can be done
professionally and if we look at you
know obviously there's evs and doing the
right thing there and doing the
recycling and composting and all the
right stuff at home and not you know
reuse don't buy all new so there's all
those kinds of consumer facing things
that need to happen but it's really
incumbent on
the innovators the companies the
individuals in the world to bring new
solutions to consumers or change out the
system without the customers even
knowing yeah to make things more
efficient because customers don't know
that 60 of all the energy created in the
world is lost what can they do about it
it just shows up so we have to go and
reboot our infrastructure in some ways
and so in many ways in almost every way
and so
there's one for me
that we're
now finally getting into which is the
hydrogen economy
so if we think about all these different
chemicals that we use today
are come out of petroleum
okay they come out from
sucking something out of the ground and
then refining it what have you plastics
is one of them
we can move to
hydrogen based economy
to create all of those products we can
create them more quickly with
no or little co2
get this similar products out
and they're actually more profitable to
be made for the companies themselves so
there's all of these things around
hydrogen like let's give you fertilizer
okay it doesn't sound sexy but we need a
lot of fertilizer in this world now
there's other ways of tackling that too
but fertilizer is a huge one concrete is
another one concrete's huge yeah
steel another one right
thermal just creating thermal you know
thermals like high temperature steam and
those kinds of things for different
industrial processes today we burn coal
natural gas or whatever
we could do it with hydrogen or we can
do with electricity right
that whole area see is unloved people
are starting to work on it they're
starting to make starting to make
inroads there but we need a lot more
work on those things
it's not just electric cars it's not
just the things that you hear about in
the in the press every day
so i think that we need to be really
thinking about the hydrogen economy and
to a certain extent the biomass economy
because we can actually turn a lot of
the the things we use today like let's
say jet fuel those can come from bio
sources trash sources not edible sources
but really trash or waste and turn those
into things that can stay carbon neutral
it's not a perfect solution because
we're using
things on the on the ground in the on
the planet right biomass but it's just
sitting there and it's going to turn
into you know co2 or methane we could
put it back in and use those things now
and we have lots of technologies to do
that so i think hydrogen economy biomass
economy not chopping down trees and just
lighting up smoke that's not what i'm
talking about here i'm saying
transforming it into chemicals and raw
materials so that they can be used not
just burning wood you know which we see
a lot of people
fudging that they say that's clean
energy it's not yeah
yeah
let's return to a term that you used
earlier that i would love to hear you
speak about just a little bit carbon
removal so i've become very interested
in the last six to 12 months in uh
different means of carbon removal so not
credit carbon credits not offsets but
actual carbon removal i've looked very
closely at what stripe has done which i
think is really innovative and inspiring
and i i would love to know if
if you have any general thoughts about
carbon removal if any particular
approaches or companies
you find
particularly interesting any comments or
thoughts at all on carbon removal
okay so
there's carbon removal from the air
okay and we see climb works and we see
other people trying to put up these big
factories so to speak to suck in sucking
air and take out co2
that may or may not scale i don't know
enough about that i always i always like
to go to where the source of the problem
is as opposed to fixing the problem to
allow other people so that's what
they're at i don't know if that's gonna
be great i hope it is we need we need
lots of solutions there's not one again
not one silver bullet so i hope they're
very successful and the
their competition around that success
but there's another one which is taking
the carbon that's already locked into
plants
and turning that into something that
stays locked into
biomass in other words
how do we take the oil that we pumped up
or coal and how do we put it back in the
ground and leave it in the ground just
like we're just storing it again not as
gas or whatever and i look at biochar
and i don't know if you know about
biochar but biochar is a way to take
various biomasses
you you you basically light them on fire
yes but at a certain degree certain
temperature certain airflow and it locks
all that carbon in
and once you put it on the ground it
stays there for thousands of years and
then gets buried under the surface and
that's what turned into
oil or coal over time which was biochar
so if we think about
today
biochar has been around for thousands of
years
now we have to do it at scale we can get
energy out of it but we can also lock
that carbon in because again if you have
dead tree trunks or whatever else sooner
or later that carbon will be emitted
maybe 50 years 100 years whatever
from the decaying mass well today we can
just take biochar lock it in you know in
a very simple process put it in the
ground get energy out and it's like it's
a win-win for all of us so those are the
kind of things when i see carbon
sequestration that's like really smart
because people are like let's just plant
more trees yes but once the trees fall
down we need to make sure that carbon
stays out of the environment how do we
do that something like biochar and
locking it in and storing
there's a third one which is carbon
capture
which is
just hooking on
carbon basically filters from smoke
stacks or whatever is coming out and
then trying to recapture that and
turning it into other products which can
be done as well yeah so i think those
are the three different areas that i see
as carbon capture and i think that all
three are are necessary
and and we should be seriously throwing
those scrubbers on sooner rather than
later especially on the co2 generators
as we start to make the transition to
much cleaner hydrogen based
manufacturing process or whatever that
are not using the old
co2 emitting processes
are there any other
or any
companies startups
or larger although i mean startups
because they're startups these days
they're getting like series a
funding at like billions and billions
and billions of dollars so it's hard for
me to even wrap my head around a lot of
that but the
are there any companies that stand out
for you in those categories i want to
say that
one you know charm industrial would fall
into the second category i believe and
i've i've been
quite impressed
by them with with the caveat that i'm
just an amateur who's still learning on
the job
but any any companies that you'd like to
mention that you think are doing a good
job
these are all small companies let's be
very clear they're trying to do the
right thing they want to do the right
thing
and
now people are really starting to rally
around them investors are
the early money and so there's another
one called carboculture they're also
doing the piochar so carboculture
is there
and they're doing doing it on mass and
they have they have their first factory
but again i want to see a factory for a
factory how they're going to make lots
of these so they can deploy them
everywhere yeah right
i'm seeing a lot of new technology i
don't have any specific companies
unfortunately right now that i can talk
about in the
kind of the smokestack scrubbing there's
a lot of new technology in terms of
membrane technology other kinds of
chemical treatment technology to extract
that co2 from those emissions and bring
them right down into some useful form so
i don't have anything right offhand i
can i should go do some lookup and i'll
give you some some things you can put in
your uh in your comments
or in your description the show notes
yeah we'll put some links in you know i
heard of one recently and i can't speak
to the company i haven't done any
diligence on this at all
but a great name it's called remora
carbon
r-e-m-o-r but it's a reference to this
uh-huh
i believe it would be categorized as a
fish that kind of hangs on the sides of
sharks and eats the scraps as the sharks
consume their own food and it's carbon
capture for trucks
so it's scrubbing
technology that is
piggybacking just like a remora
in the ocean on semi-trailer trucks so
super super exciting i mean a lot of
innovation happening right now like you
said though very much so on a small
scale so how do you make a factory for a
factory
is a great way to put it
exactly and so remora
they're doing it for trucks you know i
think those are something that can
actually move to hydrogen or ammonia
kind of propulsion they don't
necessarily have to use diesel right and
you know because those are longer haul
stuff same thing with electric
trains electric trains or hybrid trains
so yes there are a lot of these things
and some of them are stop gaps for the
next five to ten years while we
transition away from petro based economy
to a more electron-based economy yeah
all of these things are really
interesting we're trying to go for the
stuff that's the ultimate solution not
necessarily these kinds of windows of
time because to me it's like a hybrid
car sure you can get a electric gas
hybrid car but really it's two systems
that are much more complicated more
things to break let's try to get to the
end goal as opposed to this interim goal
so i i always try to look at something
where it's the destination not the
waypoint along the way
as we move to electrons
i don't know if you are open to taking a
stab at this but how do you think
geopolitics will figure into the supply
chain
for
an electron-based economy right if you
just look at
electric vehicles
ev right you look at
the
raw materials and i'm not technical
enough to know what those raw materials
are but if you look at the incredibly
good job that certain
countries are doing
which you can certainly name but in
africa in south america at establishing
china russia exactly really good
relationships on the ground they're
building infrastructure for
cities and countries and i don't want to
say in exchange but often in tandem
developing incredibly good
incredibly dominant
sourcing and distribution for a lot of
raw materials
so what do you think
that what are some plausible ways that
that develops
well i think we're seeing the reality
right now with the ukraine war that's
going on
and we're starting to understand
that
we need to have more independence in
terms of our energy supplies our raw
material supplies and we need to be
working with people
that have like
values like
ethics like morals
if we're going to truly be
we'd like it to be a global economy i
think we went down that road and we're
seeing people exploiting that to their
own gain for too long and now wanting to
rise up in a power more in a powerful
position whether they can or can i'm not
going to judge that
but i think that
we need
we being each country needs to have
their and europe is eu's i'm calling us
you know i know it's many countries but
they each need to have their own
strategic way of doing
energy sourcing
luckily as we go to electrons that's
going to be easier
because it can be done
inside the borders but from a materials
perspective there's going to have to be
many more of them
of suppliers and the reason being
is you know we kind of let monopolies
prevail and there was like oh those are
dirty those are hard businesses
actually there's a lot of interesting
businesses that can be built with new
technology that will actually help us to
find and mine things or find these
elements much more easily inside our
national borders or our our true friends
national borders so we can get these
strategic things set up
what we were witnessing in many regards
whether that's in materials minerals
manufacturing it was outsourced to the
lowest gdp country or the lowest gdp per
capita country to get that lowest cost
labor and then those things will come
back to us we're not going to see that
anymore we're going to see technology
derived
you know extraction these kinds of
things and it's going to have to be
nationally protected and it's just going
to happen more and more now that's one
thing which is the the supply but if we
also look at the technology there's
things like
non-lithium-based batteries that are
coming sulfur-based
uh sodium-based
so iron-based so we're actually able to
then
gear some of the technologies for
certain things to the resources that we
have or the abundance of resources
around the planet where it's not as
strategic
right as we hear about the rare earth
some are rare and some aren't but rare
earths and this is the reason why we
invested in that motor company turn time
is because they're not using any rare
earths right so what does that look like
when you have a different way of
creating those motors and different
partnerships that you need to be able to
do so so i think we're going to be
spending more and more time on
understanding we need to invest in
strategic capabilities and we can't just
farm it out to the lowest cost
in the world and use the logistics chain
and then we get trapped
from the geopolitical side and the war
is horrible it's devastating all those
other things but with high energy prices
guess what it makes climate change a lot
easier in terms of the rational argument
for why we need to do it from a business
perspective obviously there's an
emotional and rational to preserve our
species on the planet but some people
don't see it that way especially some
shareholders but i think we're starting
to see that it's not just doing the
right thing it's not just about us as a
society it's also the right thing
geopolitically to start to really figure
out how to
be more self-sufficient and get away
from these things and luckily we do have
technologies today that are already
available to allow
this kind of world to exist even though
we'd rather be all one thing
unfortunately not everyone
sees it the same
yeah it's uh
certainly when people get hit in the
wallet
as as intensely as a lot of people have
been with with fuel costs and will
continue to be
and it will continue to be
it sort of highlights the vulnerability
the vulnerabilities that we have if we
don't take a lot of these newer
technologies seriously and newer options
for sourcing
right exactly and frankly if you look at
our petrochemical world it's been
subsidized for decades
it has been propped up right and if you
look at when we look at inflation
i really look at it the opposite
de-inflation is stopping we've been
de-inflated we've been moving everything
offshore we've been going the lowest for
uh paying a workforce getting rid of
health care and all this other stuff
we've been just pushing the
externalities on everyone else what
we're doing to the climate now it's all
coming back to roost and that
de-inflation thing that was happening is
no longer and we're just paying we're
paying back
what we we're doing all those years
right so when people go it's being done
to us no we did that to ourselves to try
to keep prices low for so long and all
of a sudden we really pressed reset on
the whole system whether that's
workforce materials manufacturing
sourcing
now it's coming back and we're like oh
inflation no we're finally paying the
prices we should have paid maybe you
know maybe not all spread evenly we
should have been paying with a steady
increase over time
[Music]
so
you seem like an optimistic guy to me
would you would you consider yourself
optimistic
well the alternative sucks so
we'll see more about that because i
think it's
i've seen various and i
i can't cite these sources here but
polls and surveys of especially younger
people like 20 to 35
maybe even younger
who have record levels of apathy right
and pessimism yes that's a problem that
is a very very significant problem huge
especially when you consider you know a
lot of the entrepreneurs who are going
to be in the full contact kind of
professional sports of business
do a lot of great work in that band
right
so
and whether that is doesn't have to be
in the in the for-profit sector but just
people getting big things done in the
world
fall a lot of them fall in that band
how do you cultivate optimism or how
would you sell optimism to people who
are feeling apathetic when they're just
getting barraged all day long by what
they consider to be fatalistic bad news
well first
change your media diet
yeah first change your media diet and
start talking and listening to people
who actually have some
possible
solutions for the problems
now that you're tuned into the problems
that some of the problems we have go
learn about them go see how you can be
part of the solution so either you can
sit there and be apathetic
and be part of the problem or you can
move and be part of the solution right
apathy doesn't sit in the middle between
problem and solution if you are
apathetic you're part of the problem
you need to be working on the solutions
and more that you look at the solutions
and i'm seeing things for 5 7 10 years
out 15 years out
you can't help it be optimistic because
you see the stuff that's coming down
through you know from these research
labs or from these brilliant
entrepreneurs who have great ideas and
some will fail of course but a lot of
them will succeed and you start going oh
my god there is a future we can do this
if we want to embrace it we saw it with
kovit we all got together at covent just
two years ago like this week or last
week oh my god we're putting up
temporary hospitals what can we do about
testing what are we doing about new ways
of communicating the data and getting
the news stories out there and and of
course there was
misinformation all that other stuff but
look at how the world rallied together
and tried to figure this stuff out
governments did and you're like you
might even feel at least i did here in
europe a sense of leadership from the
politicians and the governments of
trying even if you might not agree
trying to do something about it
when you see that we do have that
capability as humans to help each other
and help our own as well as each other
when we know that there are climate
crisis problems out there and when you
start to see the solutions
it's hard to be
it's hard to be pessimistic or apathetic
about it because again if you are then
you're not helping to solve it right
you're not helping to be on that side be
on the other side helping to solve it
and maybe you'll see something i'm a
cautious optimist okay i'm not just a
create i used to be an optimistic
optimist i'm a cautious optimist right
or a pessimistic optimist i make sure we
pick things because there's lots of
things to pick from that can be real and
help those become real but i obviously
ask all the questions it's just not like
oh yeah that's going to be great no we
have to really dive in there's a lot of
shady people out there selling things
that don't really exist but when you
start to get on the other side of the
equation and start to look for solutions
then you can start to get optimistic so
change your media diet first and
foremost start learning think about
things you're passionate about and dive
in and learn
because there's so many resources out
there you wouldn't believe how many
things are out there and people are
needed for those and they're usually
really well paying too and you're going
to do something that's meaningful to you
to your family maybe your kids or
grandkids and it's going to help your
society and it's going to help the
planet so that when you sit at a dinner
table in 2050 with your grandkids or
whoever it is and they go oh my god we
just got past this climate crisis issue
it's always going to be lingering with
us but we got past it and your
kids or your generations people around
the table go what did you do about it
how did you solve it personally or
professional how are you part of the
solution you can actually have really
good answers
because this is an existential thing
this is not about [ __ ] metamers or
the craziness around the nft you know
gambling
this is about true problems that we have
and to your earlier point the first
trillionaire will be someone who solves
these massive problems on this planet
that we have because why because we're
not going to exist without them and
that's the biggest pain ever think about
this when you get sick or i hope you
never do but when someone gets sick what
happens they all of a sudden go i'm
gonna change my life i you know they
have a heart attack who knows what it is
god forbid anything happening but
i'm gonna change my life i'm gonna go
and they wake up to it well guess what
we have a sick planet our planet is
incredibly sick and we caused it nobody
else did we cause it maybe it's other
generations but you can't just sit
around and go well it's sick i don't
know what to do it's a family member
it's so important it's a family member
what are you doing to be on the right
side and trying
to to find solutions both personally and
professional
you're here
it's a passion man i i love this no i
know this is why i want to bring it up
so people i think will will come away
from this conversation with lots of
notes
related to everything we've discussed
are there other in terms of changing
media diet any particular
people resources could just be one or
two any anything or anyone else
you could recommend
people take a look at
to diversify get some more
sort of nutritious fiber in their
information diet well i think this is a
great great place to start which gives a
great overview speed and scale i don't
know if you can see it but that's uh
yeah
that's john doerr's latest compilation
of all kinds of different people working
on climate solutions i think that's a
really great one
the subtitle is an action plan for
solving our climate crisis now it's not
fully complete but it gives a good sense
of just reading about it i'm sure
there's podcasts about it i'm sure
john's done a lot of different ones i
think that's a really good place to get
started there's also things like my
climate journey
talks about people who are in the
industry and doing trying to to solve
things and it's just
looking at at different blogs there's
all kinds of different blogs that you
can read with daily articles about
various solutions that can get into and
there's also great podcasts too video or
youtube videos
that dive into a lot of the stuff so it
really depends on what
hopefully there's something that you
really get you really upset like why is
there so much pollution in the
environment or why is there why do we
have trash on the streets or or why is
there food waste
finding something that you really care
about and either going in it personally
or professionally and learning about it
and seeing how you can
use your your time and your passion and
turn it into or your disgust and turn it
into something positive and help
and for for people listening i'll also
include links to everything we've
discussed
in the show notes so you'll have a
couple of places to start nibbling and
exploring
at tim.blog podcast tony you're always
inspiring to talk to i always get to you
know recharge myself full of piss and
vinegar go out and tackle something
difficult so i appreciate that about you
and
i also appreciate
that you're an uncommon blend of
someone who's deeply technical but also
deeply honed i was going to say deeply
talented but
that might imply something innate which
you may also have but you've developed
the skill of storytelling and
communication and i think it's a really
formidable
combination i think i do i do think it's
it's incredibly compelling and it was
all learned you know your audience can
learn it you can learn it it's just
always thinking about the audience
thinking about the message why are you
doing this why why not what
and it's about the mission not about
your ego
and the yyy and the storytelling
plus the technical side
and a lot of details are conveyed i
think beautifully in
the new book build subtitle an
unorthodox guide to making things worth
making
and uh i am going to read a lot more of
this book i i i did a little taste
tester
over the last 24 or 48 hours and
it's very well i just want to give you
credit where credit is due it's very
well formatted
i'm amazed how many well-written books
are poorly formatted in the sense they
are simply visually difficult to absorb
but the book is formatted in such a way
that the pages are incredibly readable
and the chapters are incredibly short
so the kind of
like rat with a kind of cocaine pellet
dispenser
dopamine reinforcement used in the
positive sense i know it's a bit of
maybe an awkward uh example but it's
it's it's very
self-perpetuating
as a reader experience so i i really
encourage people
to check it out i really appreciate it
because we
i i spent a lot of time re-architecting
you know the book and trying to get it
into that that thing and and that was a
big risk it took a risk threw it out
there and see because it's
i think it's unlike other books you know
and it's like i said it's not you can
read it literally but it's really not
for that and we just want to help you
know at the end of the day just want to
help and to be truthful you know if you
buy the book
the book there is all proceeds
that come to me or any profits that come
to me they're all going to a climate
fund that i'm gonna run that i'm
matching with five times the money so
whatever comes out i'm matching it five
times and we're going to personally
manage and put that money to work in
climate crisis solutions and we're going
to continue to invest that and then over
time we'll we'll then be donating all
the profits of that as well to
climate focused uh charities so
the whole thing here is just to give
back to inspire people who are working
on tough societal health or or planet
scale problems
help them learn to
through the failures we had and to also
help the planet so trying to take
whatever comes out of it and reinvest it
because the whole world as we know is
it's circular or the everything in the
world is circular and so i want to make
sure this all goes back and i hope your
listeners your watchers will find
something find a value in the book and
go out and and and purchase it so that
you can be also helping
find the solutions to climate change
helping us find the solutions to climate
change at least so people check it out
build an unorthodox guide to making
things worth making tony fidel you can
find him on twitter and instagram at t
fidel
f-a-d-e-l-l you can find future shape on
twitter at futureshapellc
and is there anything else you'd like to
to add tony before we wrap up any
comments other requests to the
audience complaints anything so
you know at the end of the day with the
ukraine russian war that's going on we
have geopolitical tensions between china
and the rest of the world and everything
i've been trying to really understand
from a historical perspective what that
means and how technology can be brought
to bear on those things and so i've been
reading books like
the the hundred year marathon
something like this just to learn to get
from a different perspective that's by
michael pearlsbury i'm also been really
fascinated by the changing world order
by ray dalio ray dalio when you start to
look at history repeating itself it's
really insightful to help you try to
understand the world better and these
books do a great job of illuminating
those things
the other one that
i hope is going to happen and ray does a
a second edition of this book is gonna
really talk about the new technologies
for government for currency for finance
all of these things that you know in his
book he's talking about these arcs and
world order which country was on top
whether it was the uk or whether it was
the dutch and then ultimately the u.s
these kinds of things
how those changing world happen and they
almost happen all the same way i won't
give it away in the book but you should
read the book but we now have technology
for currencies for financial systems for
governmental systems for community
action and bonding that may change these
arcs
it's so disruptive they may change these
arcs and it doesn't mean
what is written in the book today will
happen tomorrow
in in the future because now technology
can change those fundamentals that have
been more or less locked in for the past
hundreds of generations so it'll be very
interesting to see how these lessons or
these historical lessons change as we
change the technology so i think those
are two really great books that people
should you know if they want to
understand a little bit while it's going
on and make sense of it those are two
really great books
wonderful thank you tony i think for a
lot of folks the starting point whether
it's prior to building a company or
educating themselves on some of these
technological innovations and possible
solutions is as you said changing your
information intake i think it's so
critical you've you've given a bunch of
recommendations on the entrepreneurial
side and also on the
climate solutions side i just think you
know garbage in garbage out so you got
to fix the garbage in piece
without a doubt yeah you just can't give
automatically any any company that wants
it root access to your brain it's a very
dangerous set of permissions to just
automatically give away so really
thinking about information intake i
think you've given some really good
guidelines so so thank you for that well
thank you thanks for the time hopefully
our discussion on your small team
management stuff maybe that can help a
little bit i don't know oh i took a ton
of notes i took a ton of notes and it's
you know it's it's incredible how
the most some of the most powerful
insights can be just hiding in plain
sight right like i was thinking in my
head of this kind of false well in a
sense like a false dichotomy of the time
sharing versus task sharing and in my
head i'm thinking well once you task
split those are set although i didn't
even phrase it in my mind because it
didn't occur to me that you would have a
rotation
right i mean it's just it's so simple
but
i needed someone to [ __ ] tell me god
it's just like how blind can you be
sometimes it's incredible
and
i'm very excited for you i know
everybody's burning the candle at both
ends right now on your team for the book
launch i think the book really stands on
its own
two feet you know a lot of people do a
big push for a book launch and at the
end of the day the book has to stand on
its own and i think the book has a lot
of really really good tactical
advice thank you so i appreciate you
taking time once again to have a
conversation with me it's nice to see
you
really appreciate it thanks tony and
to everybody listening
well first of all thank you for
listening
and until next time be a little kinder
than necessary
cultivate
optimism it is something you can
cultivate start with picking your
information sources more carefully
and i encourage you to check out the
book build an unorthodox guide to making
things worth making by tony fidel and
once again until next time
thank you for tuning in thank you
you